good morning Togo good morning guys
we've been back home for a few weeks
we've been working nonstop and it is
time to work again but this morning I
don't really feel like making breakfast
so I'm thinking about taking you guys to
the best most amazing breakfast spot
it's not the best breakfast spot it's
just the best restaurant in the world
and I think we need to take too and
chibi too chibi restaurant never
mind Hey Jo good morning good morning uh
what did I hear about the best
restaurant in the
world do you want to go to the best
restaurant in the world for some
breakfast yes all right let's go let's
go he knows exactly where we're going I
just need to check in with Nikita yes hi
good morning good morning I don't feel
like breakfast we didn't even make up
the bed yet no we haven't so I'm just
quickly how about we go to the best
restaurant in the world oh yes never
mind I'm in let's go we didn't even get
ready yet I still need to do my hair we
need to make up the bed do a few things
get Togo and chibi and then we're going
to go to the most amazing restaurant in
the world
surey so fluffy chibi you're too fluffy
too much
fluff Jo do you want to take too then
I'll dry man they love going out they
can't wait huh tooi never
mind they know what's waiting
all right let's
go
I
set okay let
go let's go let's go let's go go too fat
too go go go go to go go to go go you
can do it all right sorry let's help
him oh
all
right all right everybody's in here we
go let's go so the awesome thing about
never mind is that you can take your
pets with of course you need to sit
outside but um and they need to be on a
leash right but the the most amazing
thing is is not just the food I mean the
food that's incredible but uh it is all
about the location and the people and
the atmosphere all right so we live in a
place called St Frances Bay and just a
few kilometers
is capes and Frances beautiful houses
beautiful people down to earth people
and so it's the whole atmosphere so this
place clicks all the boxes I've been to
a lot of places even
eating in front of a Master Chef in
Japan sushi but this place beats all of
the places I've ever been to almost over
countries
hello he just lying there
woo yeah actually get carck Daniel oh
little T but it's not too far
[Music]
yeah Danel you're driving a rough no no
no but look here everything is in the
road there's like chickens there's
people there's dogs there dogs dogs that
we might not like them if you see them
and then uh there's pigs around here as
well that we
[Music]
sawo you excited huh
so this is Cape St Francis
everyone go
here way too excited yeah
man this is beautiful this is
[Music]
it all right we here about uh the dogs
they've got too much energy so we're
just going to walk them we're going to
put the Drone up in the air Jo's going
to do that for us and we're going to
show you how beautiful this place really
is now I don't think Togo and chibi they
saw the Drone yet and when this thing
lifts off I think they're going to get a
big
scare to's running
away chibi is not hey Chi's just like
this is cool he doesn't like it at all
he's hiding what's it
too it's up in the air
now too doesn't like it at all don't
worry buddy don't worry let's go let's
go we're going to
[Music]
walk
wow check out all these shells so many I
mean it's just there's just so many here
wow what is that so we call this in
Africans Pinki which if you directly
translate it is
pumpkin wow now if you do come here
please don't take all these shells away
because if everybody comes and everybody
takes a lot of shells at the end there's
nothing left and that's what happened
around the rest of the
world
wow
nice South Africa really is a beautiful
country everywhere you look you see
these flowers in purple
yellow and then the beautiful ocean of
course so what I feel like when I live
here in South Africa is it's more rugged
it's more like
old country you know like the old world
where it's
untouched and I love it wow look at
these beautiful
[Music]
waves
there's a big wave
coming wow I'm going to get a
wi it can be very dangerous so we don't
want to get closer we actually want to
go back now is getting high tied and
there's a lot of fishermen who die
because they take chances with Mother
Nature I'm not one of those fishermen
and today I'm not
fishing let's go back these small legs
are tired now a shame chibi are you
tired yeah so go let's go this
way I think that was a good idea their
energy is out so now it'll be easier to
go sit down and have breakfast and then
you guys see the lighthouse there behind
me you can book a night and you can
sleep there they can bring the food to
you as well it's quite special we'll
show you what it looks
[Music]
like look at this you are now at the
Southeastern most tip of Africa Seal
Point Point Cape San
Francis
man there's some beautiful fish that you
can catch from here the whole Garden
Route up until Cape Town and I think
that should be our next Vlog catching
some tuna in South
Africa they get big Yellow Tail
tuna you're going to stay here with the
dogs yes I have to stay outside with
enjoy all right byebye bye
1878 it's quite old oh
nice oh so this is the place where they
bring you the food where you sleep this
is the place where you can sleep very
nice look how old it is Jo H cool like
the aesthetic over here you have a
kitchen wow look at this old
stove H that's so cool got a fridge of
there washing
area wow this is nice
all right ooh look at the shower check
this
out you guys want to come here I'll add
all the links for you in the video
description down
below and then ooh look at this this is
quite nice
huh all
right oh is a nice view oh awesome yeah
you can see the waves there
nice Jo I think you can
go
okay all right here think
you so if you do come here remember just
to put this
in there so you didn't fall through so
many videos where Daniel Falls yeah
okay that's
comtable
oo oh you can hear the echo EO
woohoo and this is where you go
up the
lighthouse it's actually a bit
[Music]
B Construction began 1 March
oh just the door
opening hear that
Echo it's kind of scary yeah I'm not
going to talk a lot because the echo is
a bit
[Music]
crazy there's a whale as well joob I
don't think you guys can see it with the
with the GoPro because it's too far
we'll have to use the Drone
[Music]
yes let's go
up be careful if you walk here
almost
w this is so
small wow they've got some
history lighthous Keeper in France is
from 1975 to
1987 that's
[Music]
un lighter houses saved a lot of lives
what they do is they give out the light
every few seconds and every Lighthouse
is different in different countries so
when people are on ships they count when
they see the light maybe after 3 seconds
every time other countries maybe 6
seconds and then they know all right
they are not close to South Africa for
example very interesting how L houses
work very
cool
oh we're not there
yet man so
Ste ah you made it there's more there's
more
okay look at how steep this
is not
[Music]
fun
yeah it's quite high up
already I think it's the last little bit
you go first you don't like height no no
can just imagine what it's going to look
like at the top
so I might stay
inside get even steeper here we
[Music]
go you can bump your head
easily
this is quite nice yeah maybe best
three okay here we
are oh here's the um
generators and the gear is sending the
light I
believe look at the view J wow man
beautiful huh that is
amazing there's the restaurant on
they this is why it's so beautiful
you've got the ocean day and you've got
it day as
well I'm kind of shaking a bit looking
down especially I'm trying to look there
look at those people down there yeah
it's it's pretty high
it's quite hot yeah I'm a bit more
stressed about the way
down at the than I was with the way
out this is the light man this is this
is intense and this is why as reborn
Christians you know we should be the
light of the world not hiding sharing
the gospel in boldness in truth and in
love too many Christians out there are
are afraid
and they're not a sweet smelling Aroma
to other people some Christians are very
judgmental we should be the light of the
world light attracts and brings people
out of
Darkness this is why we have uh the
merch of the lighthouse as well you can
get it check it out in the video
description I like this smell in
here
youri let's go let's
go let's go this way
oops
[Music]
oh look at
this hm morning morning hello good
morning good morning how are you good
and you good to see you I told you the
people were friendly
here
huco thank you you already know we want
cappuccino right got the best coffee all
right let's go sit down here okay the
cool thing is they have these spots
here where you can just keep keep your
dogs close to you there we go some water
this thing is really cool if you have
fits look at that the water just
comes like that if you press the
button
oh okay wait wait to go just wait a bit
there we
go and if there's a little bit left over
you just press the button again and you
do that and it all slowly goes back
in
all right there you go thank you there's
the best coffee in the
world there we go thank you so much
thank you
enjoy oh now the day can start with good
coffee my goodness so the menu man
everything here is unique you won't get
this really at at other places the
normal General
restaurants Wow and the the problem with
that is you never know what to choose
let me show you it's alling eggs eggs
Your Way Green Eggs and Ham ooh Nikita
you like this yes I love Green Eggs and
Ham olive oil crispy fried eggs cabou
wow that's I don't even how know I don't
even know how to pronounce that jimy
Chuy permes and fresh sarda ooh salmon
tartar I might choose that peas please
this is interesting sardo toast peas
avocado ricota pesto poached
egg tomatoes on toast mushrooms on toast
sourdough blueberry oh my
goodness you see why I like this
place what are you guys going to choose
I think today because it's summer so I'm
going to go for a granola Bowl oh Jo uh
I think the stuff that I can
pronounce eggs
yeah uh I still need to
[Music]
check are you guys ready to order or not
yes yes I am good you guys as well yeah
I'm going to take the pece please PE
please you don't have the L anymore his
favorite and how do you like your potion
so medium medium yeah I like it
tasty um I'm going to have the granola B
granola bow yes thank you for you I will
take green eggs man eggs soft please
soft pleas thank you so much thank you
thank you one thing I want to quickly
tell you guys is you can't feel the wind
just on your skin you can't feel the
weather you can't feel anything when we
just show you the camera but just know
and trust us that the atmosphere here is
perfect and that it is peaceful that's
what you find here peaceful and then the
good food that's the bonus is the bonus
yeah yeah the location is beautiful it's
all about the location we've got the sea
on this side we've got the Sea on the
other side and then there are whales
here as well that you can always watch
oh that's
[Music]
beautiful
and we are not paying to do this yes
this is not a sponsored video at all we
just we just really wanted to share with
you guys the the Excellence of this
place in in every aspect like Daniel
said there food off
evad yeah a little bit of Peace before
we have to go back to work
yeah
yes that's thank
you thank you so much oh wow thank
you very
nice for your bread uh yes please thank
and also a Coke like all right thank you
so much PE please oh my goodness I've
had that before and it's great
ooh nice looks so
ay Jo what do you have this is ham and
eggs and it looks great man this is not
normal ham and eggs no this is never
[Laughter]
mind
smile here we go Coke lights thank you I
enjoy thank you so much for the light
side of life for the light side of this
is awesome I think we need to pray yes
please father thank you so much for this
little time together here with Jo and a
would you please bless the food in Jesus
name we pray amen amen amen let's dig
in um I think if summer would have
tasted like something it would have
tasted like
this that looks like summer mhm fresh
and summery and light it's great I love
an and I love never mind I'm even more
look at
that how's that too I think too is
hungry Nikita does he want give him a
snacky
yeah
ayy oh so
good
so Niko you switched around a bit huh
because of the sun bit because the sun
is just too hot oh yeah oh there's a big
dog coming over there helloo is he
friendly can I fit him yeah yeah name's
Daisy hey
hello it's a big dog Togo huh that's a
big dog
you want to climb on huh okay all right
all right all right there we go there we
go is that better sit chibi is noticing
the big
dogs just want to show you guys the vibe
inside this is quite special and then
this is where these amazing guys are
preparing the best food how are you guys
doing put didn't use all good all
good
wa venison right yeah yeah this is a BL
B we got like th from a hunt so we do
some there's some hunting our goes
hunting for like venison every few
months and then we have like a stock
pile that we have left in our freezer we
just nice so you guys will see that the
menu at night when you come here is
totally different from the breakfast
menu
maybe I need to show
you as you can see it's evening now and
a lot has
changed look at those cob Cabo in aans
now they're preparing different food
here so it's only me and Jo Nikita she
had to do some work so I'm just going to
show you the vibe here at
evening this is a nice private spot if
you want to sit here and eat and have
some privacy and then also a nice fire
over
here
[Music]
some table 43
please guys we away now one fish one f
[Music]
it you guys remember the venison from
earlier today it is
ready I want to eat this for the rest of
my life just look at that
perfect perfectly medium
rare
[Music]
wow that was amazing it's a shame n
couldn't join us because he had meetings
but look how beautiful the lighthouse is
at
[Music]
night all right back
homeo chibio chibi hello hello hello
buddy hello chibi hello guys it's been
amazing amaz we're back home J how was
that meat oh man that was amazing best
steak I've had yeah I have to agree but
you know being next to the ocean today
it made me want to go fishing for
tuna so I think that sounds great the
next video that's what we're going to do
but first up we need to work a few weeks
and then we we're going to go fishing so
if you haven't subscribed yet please do
so you won't miss that video and always
remember life is short so don't waste
yours cheers guys